AUDIENCE: We're
going to be trying
to use Dart to handle tens or
hopefully hundreds of thousands
of simultaneous
socket connections.
So we looked at it with
Node.js, Dart, Java.
You can make a C server
that uses epoll directly.
So Dart was better than
node, but it wasn't better
than Java or C by a long shot.
And I was curious if
anybody on the team
is looking at this problem to
make a super-scalable server.
SETH LADD: Sorry,
one quick-- did
everyone hear that or
do we need to repeat?
OK.
Cool, go ahead.
Who would like to answer?
IVAN POSVA: I didn't
hear the question.
SETH LADD: Oh, I didn't ask
my panel if somebody heard it.
Sorry.
Can you repeat?
And speak right into it, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Basically, we want 100,000
simultaneous socket connections
to a Dart server and we
want it to scale well,
within a factor of two
or three from what we
would get with C and epoll.
Is there anybody
looking at that?
IVAN POSVA: I know we have been
looking at it with the server
team.
Probably should reach you
with Soren after the break
here, but we've had ideas
on scaling with isolates
and basically handing
off requests to isolates.
AUDIENCE: It could be
in the same isolate.
We basically-- probably I've
only looked at this problem
very briefly, I'll admit.
But when I looked
at it, I wanted
to see where-- in Java, you
have NIO, which kind of you
can see how that maps to
epoll on a Linux system.
Other operation systems
have something like epoll.
What does that interface
look like in Dart?
There doesn't seem to be-- it's
very, very deep, kind of buried
in lots of syncs and so forth.
So is that maybe something
that can be exposed at a lower
level to a Dart programmer?
IVAN POSVA: So if you
use the raw socket API,
then you get essentially what
epoll is behind the scenes.
So that's how it works
behind the scenes.
I don't know how
much of the streams
and so on add as an overhead.
That's something that we
should probably measure.
But there is a raw
socket that you
could use that is a little
bit more low-level, if you're
looking forward to that.
LARS BAK: I just want to
add that a good start is
to send us a benchmark so
we see what the problem is.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Who do we thumb that to, or
can I talk to you later maybe?
LARS BAK: Yes.
Just file a bug with
a benchmark attached.
SETH LADD: Cool.
Thank you.
Before we get to
the next question--
and please keep
continuing to queue up--
welcome to the panel.
Again, we've had a lot
of great opportunity
to talk to various
different engineers here
and we hope to continue that.
We're here for you,
so ask us questions.
But we also asked online with
our moderators who queued up
a lot of questions here.
We want to talk to you.
And to kick it off, I hope we
can introduce our panelists.
So I could do it, but it'd be
a lot more interesting if they
can introduce themselves.
We can learn who they
are, what makes them tick.
So Lars, can you
introduce yourself?
LARS BAK: My name is Lars Bak.
I barely tick.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm one of the
founders of Dart, has
been working on virtual
machines the last 30 years.
So I care about performance.
I care about
predictable performance.
I care about making
programs productive.
That's it.
KASPER LUND: Yeah, my
name is Kasper Lund
and I've been working with
Lars for the last 15 years
doing various different virtual
machine implementations.
And the latest project
here is the Dart product
that I co-founded.
So right now, I'm working
on providing a good runtime
system for iOS and
on investigating
what we can do to make
isolates a lot easier to use.
DAN RUBEL: My name's Dan Rubel.
I work on the analyzer team.
I care about making
sure that Dart
is easy and understandable,
that the tooling is fast
and provides useful
information to the user
to increase the productivity.
IVAN POSVA: I'm Ivan Posva.
I'm the lead for the VM team.
What I care about is
making sure that the Dart
VM is applicable on
the tiniest devices
that you'll see this afternoon
to services running an app
engine and a massive server.
So basically, being able to
be elastic between those two
extremes with the VM is
what I really care about.
DAN GROVE: And I'm Dan Grove.
I work on the Dart for
Web team and obviously, I
care about Dart for the web and
making web developers really
productive.
SETH LADD: And my
name is Seth Ladd.
I'm a product manager on Dart.
And just because
I'm on the Dart team
doesn't mean I'm not
going to be sending
the hard-hitting questions
to our panelists like,
can Lars microwave a burrito
so hot even he can't eat it?
I'm going to let that
sink in for a second.
And Dart-- great language
or greatest language?
[LAUGHTER]
KASPER LUND: Yes.
SETH LADD: Anyway, OK, cool.
So let's turn it
back to questions.
Yes, you have a
question for our panel.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
If you got "get out
of feature" card,
what feature would you
like to remove from Dart?
Just one feature for each
of the members, please.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH LADD: Cool, OK.
[GRUNTS]
[LAUGHTER]
Are we still live streaming?
LARS BAK: Yes.
So I can take one.
It's just my personal one.
We took some features
from JavaScript
and moved that into Dart.
So it's easy to move
from JavaScript to Dart.
One thing I don't like is
the implicit extraction
of closures.
I should like to
have that explicit
so I can see in the code
if you extract a closure.
Because often, if you forget
to put in parentheses,
right, you take out a closure.
I want that to be back.
SETH LADD: Anyone else?
KASPER LUND: I can go.
I think one thing
that would be very
interesting to try
to remove from Dart
is all the asynchrony.
It's a little bit
controversial, but it's
kind of a thing that
would be fun to see
how far we can take something
that isn't asynchronous.
Clearly, there's a need for
asynchronous operations,
but it would be
fun to take the--
SETH LADD: What
would you put back?
It feels like you're
taking something away.
KASPER LUND: Yeah, synchronous.
SETH LADD: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
LARS BAK: And Kasper
is fully aware
that that will not
work in the browser.
KASPER LUND: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
LARS BAK: Hey, Dan?
SETH LADD: Sorry, for the what?
DAN GROVE: Big nums.
Those who are still working
the web, not really an option.
SETH LADD: Cool.
Thank you for the question.
Let's go to the first
highest-voted question
here in our moderator.
And I think we touched
a little bit about this,
but it'd be nice to get
the answer for the stream.
With the Dart VM not
going in Chrome anymore,
what kinds of JavaScript interop
improvements are we planning?
For example, would we be able
to write functions or Polymer
elements in Dart,
compile them to JS,
and distribute them
as JS libraries?
DAN GROVE: So yeah, very--
lots of JS improvements.
Yes, yes, and yes
is the short answer.
And we talked about
this some yesterday.
Jacob Richman also hit
this in his lightning talk,
for those of you that were here.
We're doing a ton of
improvements to JS interop
to make it feel really natural.
And I should-- an
example of this
in Kevin's and my
talk yesterday,
it's going to actually
feel very good.
As long as you're
calling into something
that exposes sort of Dart-ish
interface to the outside world,
it's going to feel
very natural and you're
going to be able to
get all the tooling
support that you're used
to, so code completion,
all that kind of stuff.
SETH LADD: Cool, thanks.
DAN GROVE: And yes, all the
other questions are yes.
You will be able to
write functions in Dart
and compile and distribute
them to JS developers.
SETH LADD: Great.
Again, if there's any live
questions, please queue up.
We'll go to the
next question here.
Is it possible for the Dart VM
to match the JVM's performance
on numeric computational
heavy benchmark--
IVAN POSVA: Yes.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
OK, good.
IVAN POSVA: Did
you want to finish?
SETH LADD: On Box2D.
So maybe we can
talk a little bit.
We did something
with Box2D recently
and what's your perspective
on the question?
IVAN POSVA: So specifically
on numeric computations,
we have a couple benchmarks
that are not Box2D.
Box2D is kind of a special case,
where our internal benchmark
harness, I don't think we
share those numbers externally
because of licensing issues.
But there's some fluid
motion simulation and stuff
like that, where we
are essentially equal
or on parity with the Java VM.
For Box2D, it's a
little bit harder,
because there are many different
implementations of Box2D.
And a surgeon on my team-- he's
somewhere in the audience--
just recently rewrote
the Dart version
of Box2D based on
the Java version
and the results are quite
impressive from both Dart
to JS.
And the VM significantly
improved on that.
And I think the
numbers that he quoted
me were around four milliseconds
per frame on the Java VM
and about five and a bit
milliseconds per frame
on the Dart VM.
I hope we can basically
get more stuff going there.
The Dart VM is much younger
than HotSpot or any of the JVMs
that are out there.
So we hope to catch up.
But the tight feedback
that we get at runtime
makes up for most of the or
all of the static feedback
that you can get.
Yes?
LARS BAK: I have a
[INAUDIBLE] comment.
So pretty sure that JVM
is doing a good job,
because in Java,
you can do inlining
or you basically
have basic types.
In the Dart VM, it's
more complicated
because you have to
offer-- or sometimes,
if you're not
inlining everything,
you have to sort of materialize
the results in the heap.
So it varies with
benchmarks how fast
we can get compared to the JVM.
Now, the question is, is
Box2D a real problem for you
Dart developers?
Because when it
comes to benchmarks,
we can always improve it by
just throwing resources at it.
But does it matter?
In the presentations I've seen
in the last one and a half
days, I have not seen
that to be an issue.
I'm more concerned about getting
performance of factored code
for these kinds of
applications you are writing.
So we can get as
fast as you want,
but the question is
whether we want to spend
the resources doing so.
IVAN POSVA: But this
question was specifically
about numeric
computation, right?
LARS BAK: Yeah.
IVAN POSVA: On factor code,
if it's a lot of virtual calls
and so on, we are actually
at the speed of HotSpot
and sometimes even better.
LARS BAK: Yeah.
SETH LADD: Ivan, I think
there's a question about this
a little bit later, but it
segues in perfectly from here.
It's something that we talked
to a lot of developers about.
Maybe we can sort of get
on record and discuss this.
I talked to a lot of
developers that say,
Dart's not amply-typed.
You can use var a lot,
so it has to be slower
than statically-typed languages.
So can you explain a little
bit from the VM engineering
perspective or the language
design perspective,
where the intersection is
for type annotations, how
we use them, how
we don't, and how--
what are the impacts of that for
performance, if there are any?
That's a lot.
IVAN POSVA: Is that
a question of me?
SETH LADD: Of the panel.
IVAN POSVA: Well, for
the VM specifically,
whether you type your variables
or not doesn't matter at all.
So basically, the
first thing we do
when we parse it,
unless you run in
checked mode, we throw
them away, right?
We're not concerned about them
because based on the language
spec, we cannot use
them at all, right?
We have to think dynamically
whatever the selector was.
So what we do collect
is as you keep running,
we collect what are the
types that you're actually
seeing here dynamically and make
optimizations based on that.
And that basically gives us
the exact subtypes potentially
that are being used
here to dispatch,
versus if you do
static typing, it
would be basically, OK, you're
calling this function on one
of the subclasses that
is being passed here
or could be passed here.
And for us, since we collect
all of the information,
we know exactly in
this case, it's only
going to be this subclass
and we optimize for that.
And we have to back out if
we made a misprediction.
LARS BAK: An extra
comment here is
that the types of
annotation you see
in Dart programs,
the interface types,
they're not implementation
types so they don't work really
well for the VM, anyways.
You need the actual
implementation types in order
to do the proper inlining.
IVAN POSVA: Yeah, it works well.
It works well.
LARS BAK: And I
think even if you
look at what machines
like the JVMs,
if you go back in time
when they got the big boost
in performance, it was based
on dynamically analyzing
what was going on at
runtime, not by doing
ahead-of-time
compilation or basing it
on the types of the program.
So we are just
taking the Dart VM
to the next level, where
everything is dynamic.
But we can certainly get
the same kind of benefits.
SETH LADD: Yep.
Great, thank you.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I really love what
the Dart team does
for making the tooling perfect.
And from my point of
view, there is one kind
of little step which left which
would be super cool to have,
which is-- so is there any plans
on implementing hot swapping
of the code in the VM?
I understand this is a
super complex problem.
KASPER LUND: So we
are certainly looking
into interactive or
live programming, where
you can change the
code as it's executing.
It's something that actually
would work pretty well
in the VM, too, I think, with
the very dynamic approach
the VM takes to things.
It's also something we think
has a real shot at making
a big difference in a mobile
setting, where the tool
chain's a little bit heavier
and where the ability
to update code while it's
running on your smartphone
without having to recompile
it would be pretty powerful.
So I think it's in
the cards for us
to explore that in
the coming months
and have a good
solution for that.
AUDIENCE: Oh, can't wait.
Thank you.
SETH LADD: Thank you
for the question.
Let's go back to the moderator.
And I think this touches
on some of the conversation
I've had online or in person
here about Dart Editor.
So this question's phrased as,
"Are there any improvements
to the Dart Editor
coming with regard
to working with other
JavaScript libraries,
like code completion
with JavaScript?"
But I think it's
also a good time
for us to address the
various different tooling
options we have and what is
the strategy for Dart tooling
and what editors do we recommend
and will continue to support.
DAN RUBEL: We're moving
away from Dart Editor.
Dart Editor was designed
initially to serve two masters
and that's a problem.
One, you have an
early adopter who's
learning Dart, who's literally
just getting started.
And you want to provide
a really easy on-ramp.
The other audience you
want to try to serve
are the power developers
who are building big apps
and want all of the power
at their fingertips.
It is really difficult to serve
those two needs simultaneously
with the same product.
It was a conscious decision
to separate those two.
Dart Pad, as you heard
earlier, is focused entirely
on lowering the barrier
completely to almost a zero
to get people started.
You can try out things.
It's low friction,
low resistance.
You can share it.
You can put things
in Stack Overflow,
put references, et cetera.
That serves one purpose.
The other goal is to provide
rich experience in tools
that developers are
already familiar with,
Webstorm being the primary one.
But that's not alone.
The Webstorm is
our primary focus,
but secondarily
would be continue
to take that same infrastructure
that we have for Dart Editor
and put it into Eclipse.
So you have Eclipse,
Sublime-- which there already
exists a plug-in
for that-- vi, Emax,
our interest-- we don't
have anything there yet
but they're of interest.
So the key is to provide the
analysis, the infrastructure
where the developers are.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, and just to go
back to the original question
here about JavaScript
libraries, one of the things
that we showed yesterday is
that we're working on some stub
generation, given type
script definition files,
and that will make
it much easier.
That'll fit right
into all the analysis
services that are out there.
SETH LADD: Great, thank you.
Don, question?
AUDIENCE: All right.
So one of the things
we haven't really
talked about too much
during the summit
is what the roadmap
is for Polymer Dart.
Obviously, Polymer
JS has the 0.8
and there are a number of
performance improvements.
And additionally,
at this time, you
can actually share your
elements with other people
unless they are using
the Dart ecosystem.
So what's the game plan here?
DAN GROVE: Well,
the game plan has
a couple of different pieces.
One is we're waiting
for the Polymer team
to reach a point of
stability with Polymer, which
sounds like it's coming
pretty soon, according
to things I've heard recently.
So we're not going to do
this kind of following around
Polymer change by change.
But as Polymer reaches
1.0, we are going
to provide Polymer Dart 1.0.
Second angle on this is
what we talked about some
with Dev compiler and
JS interop yesterday,
which is the ability
to take Dart libraries
and ship them to JavaScript
developers or Dart
developers for that matter.
We don't really want to care who
the consumer of components is.
So that's coming.
So with the combo of Polymer
reaching stability and Dev
compiler, I think we'll
actually be able to do the thing
that you want to do, which is
shipping Polymer components
and not caring who
your consumers are.
SETH LADD: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SETH LADD: Thanks
for the question.
So I like this question.
So if Fletch and Sky
succeed as experiments,
what are the next plan?
But what of the outcome
counts as succeeding?
KASPER LUND: Well,
it's hard for us
to speak to the plans
for the Sky project.
You should all come to
the presentation at 5:00
and see what that is and
ask questions afterwards.
But in terms of Fletch, there's
a very non-experimental part
of Fletch, which is this
runtime system for iOS.
And we showed in the
keynote yesterday
that we're going to ship that
this year as a product you
can use to ship mobile
apps for iOS on top of.
There are experimental
things in Fletch,
as well, for instance,
the isolate work
that we've started.
And clearly, if we find
that that is so compelling
that people actually want
to and need to use it,
we will find a way of
making that non-experimental
and putting it into
our product offerings.
So a success for
us would be people
being able to actually use
this to build something
truly fantastic on top of making
isolates a lot easier to use.
So I think the answer's--
SETH LADD: The developers
are more productive,
developers are happy with
this, and developers are taking
it to build really cool things.
That's success to me.
KASPER LUND: Yeah.
SETH LADD: Cool, OK.
This is a good one here.
So what kind of
performance differences
are expected between Fletch
Interpreter, JVM's JIT,
Dart to JS in the
JavaScript VM--
how will Fletch perform
relative to using
iOS's built-in JavaScript JIT?
So there's a lot in
there, but maybe we
can talk about the different
fundamental ways we approach
the compilation running.
And what are the trade-offs for
these different environments?
KASPER LUND: That's
probably for me, as well.
So the Fletch system is a very
simple system designed to run
really well in an iOS context,
where you cannot do any
just-in-time compilation.
So we do byte code
interpretation there,
and that's sort of
inherently slower
than doing just-in-time
compilation.
We're focusing on actually
delivering something you can
use to build real apps there.
And later today, I'll show
something running on an iPad
so you can see for yourself
that it's fast enough, at least
for certain things.
But it's going to be
really hard for us
to compare the performance
between all these things.
It really depends on
what you're running.
For certain micro-benchmarks,
using an interpreter
is a lot slower than
having a real JIT.
But for other
things, it's probably
fine for writing
real applications.
So it's a really difficult
question to answer.
The nice thing is that we all
dream about making performance
faster and that's really
what we like to do.
So we have a strong
background in that.
So we expect to be able
to improve Fletch a lot
in the performance
side, as well.
LARS BAK: So one
comment about iOS
is that you're
allowed to generate
code inside an iOS app.
So the question
about how will Fletch
perform compared to the
built-in JavaScript JIT?
It'll be slower, because
we cannot generate code
on the fly.
That's just how it is.
We didn't make the
rules for that system.
However, we also know how
to make interpretation fast.
And you can actually do
some pre-compilation.
You can do profiling of
the application and bundle
pre-compiled code with the app,
if that turns out to be useful.
And we'll soon be looking at
these options moving forward.
SETH LADD: Ivan, can
you talk a little bit
about what the VM's
general strategy is?
Is there an interpreter
in the beginning
before it does machine code?
What happens when it starts
to look at that code?
IVAN POSVA: Well, it
doesn't run in iOS.
But in general,
what we do is we try
to make the simple
thing happen, which
is we use the same compiler in
multiple modes of optimization.
One is just unoptimized code.
We basically read and scan
the source code in parts
and immediately
generate code out of it.
That code is instrumented to
make all these optimizations
that I talked about possible.
So it collects the type
feedback for all the calls.
Depending on what
calls there are,
we actually collect feedback
on the types of parameters
so that we know, this is
not just a plus on a double.
It's also a plus on a double
with integer parameters
all the time.
So we can basically do
the upgrade to a double
on the fly there, as well.
All these kind of things are
collected in unoptimized code,
what we call it.
And then basically,
at some point,
the VM decides this code is hard
enough and will optimize it.
And as it optimizes
further and further,
it will start
doing more inlining
and basically collects
all these-- you've
taken this branch all the time,
this cell's case is an unused,
so we'll basically just
not compile it all.
SETH LADD: Cool.
I think this is a question
here for Dart for the web.
With a shift away
from a VM in Chrome
to compiling to JavaScript,
have the metrics for success
or the metrics for quality or
the metrics for performance
have changed?
And another way
to ask this would
be, we work with a lot
of internal customers.
What are the things that are
important to them as a proxy
or important to every developer?
DAN GROVE: Yeah, I
think that's right.
I didn't hear a lot of
people worry about Delta Blue
performance yesterday,
but I do hear
a lot of people talking
about things like code size.
So when I look at the
metrics for success,
I really think that
they're becoming
more JavaScript-centric
in a lot of ways.
So we're talking
about code size.
It's really critical.
We're talking about
readability of code
and that's another
really critical thing.
We're talking about
reusability of code.
There are a bunch
of metrics there.
And in addition, the benchmarks
that we're going to be running
are going to be changing.
And I think you're going to
be seeing the Dart for web
benchmarks moving to be
much more web-centric
and looking more like
components that we
want to be able to operate with
a certain level of performance.
SETH LADD: And this is
a related question here
about Angular 2.0.
If I parse this correctly,
I think we're asking,
from Angular.I/O, the website
and the way Angular's being
written, talk to me a little
bit about where the relationship
between typescript
and Dart here.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, so this
is an interesting question.
If you visit Angular.I/O,
it's actually really nice.
You'll see that Dart and
JavaScript are basically
presented side by
side for users.
The fact that Angular is being
written in typescript itself
I think is not
really that relevant.
What's relevant is what
kinds of interfaces
they provide to Dart developers.
And we have a number of internal
users at Google that are really
pushing on the Angular team
to ensure that Angular Dart
or Angular 2.0 Dart is just as
nice to use Angular 2.0 .JS.
So I think that this is
going to be a great story.
Developers who are
using Angular will
be able to choose the
language they want.
To some extent,
they're going to be
able to mix and match things.
So they'll be able
to use Angular 2.0
components in an Angular
2.0 Dart app and vice versa.
So I actually like
this story a lot here.
We're not trying to dictate
to people what they should
be using, but we're
about offering choices
while still using
the same framework.
SETH LADD: Little things.
And again, if you want a
question for the panel,
please come up to
the microphone.
So I know Kenneth.
I think what he's really
asking here is, ES6 I hear
has a lot of things in it.
Does it have all the
things that Dart has?
And I think this is
actually really important,
because I do talk to a lot
of developers who are like,
ES6 is getting classes, so Dart?
But when I look at
under the covers,
there's a ton going on in Dart
and a lot more that I actually
need and want.
So this would be a good
time to say, what are some
of the things that Dart brings
that ES6 isn't even touching?
Or how do I evaluate the two?
Lars?
LARS BAK: This will, of course,
be a little bit of a color
to answer.
But I like to clear semantics
and I think Dart has that.
There's no implicit
conversion of values,
like there is in JavaScript.
And ES6 is still JavaScript.
Nothing has changed.
Libraries can still
be manipulated
on the fly and wreck
composition when
you build up an application.
So I still think that some
of the initial goals of Dart
are still valid.
And I don't want to make this
sort of into a religious war,
but I still believe that we
have a good set of batteries
included in Dart, which
is adding classes will not
solve all problems in my mind.
So I think Dart still
has a lot to offer.
And we can ask you guys.
What do you think?
Have you tried ECMAScript 6?
KASPER LUND: No?
LARS BAK: Any of you?
KASPER LUND: Wow.
LARS BAK: Well--
KASPER LUND: Two guys.
LARS BAK: Oh, there's two guys.
And what do you think?
AUDIENCE: Dart is
more time-safe,
so it gives you all the niceties
of using the tooling around it.
But ECMAScript or ES6
is still really flexible
and it's an improvement
on JavaScript.
But for making a
large application,
I still prefer Dart.
LARS BAK: Yeah.
SETH LADD: Cool.
LARS BAK: I agree.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN RUBEL: OK, moving on.
SETH LADD: Can you sum
that up for the people
who didn't hear it?
DAN RUBEL: Still prefers Dart.
LARS BAK: Yes, the
audience do prefer--
DAN RUBEL: A+++,
would use Dart again.
LARS BAK: I think
the static types
we have in Dart makes
the programs readable.
It makes it easier
to maintain code.
A lot of program languages
are easy to write
the code in the first time.
But when you have to go back
to the same piece of code
two months later
or a year later,
you want to be able to
understand what's going on.
And I think in that scenario,
Dart really has an advantage.
KASPER LUND: Well said.
SETH LADD: OK.
We answered a bunch of the
questions, so I moved on.
And we're almost
out of time here.
Oh, we have a live question.
Great.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: I know we talk a
lot about the interoperability
with JavaScript on
the client side,
but I'm wondering about bridging
or other interoperability
on the server side.
I know that for the
work that we do,
we have a lot of required
libraries and stuff that are
built in C# or Java or something
else that we have no choice.
I'm looking for ways
to try to bring that
in with a Dart server.
Is there any plans
in that direction?
LARS BAK: Ivan?
IVAN POSVA: So currently, if
you're running in a standalone
VM, right, you can embed C++
libraries or C libraries or any
native libraries with
just a shared object.
So load that in and you have
basically some Dart interface
that you can talk that way.
Apart from-- sorry.
Apart from that, maybe
having some RPC service
would help you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
In general, it's about
speed, because we
do a lot of heavy computation
for satellite mission planning
and control applications.
So we do a lot of--
we get requests
in from the client and stuff
and we do a lot of work on it.
Using an RPC service or
some other standard protocol
takes a lot of time to
communicate that information
around.
So sometimes, they
provide us these libraries
so that we can do a
lot of it very fast.
So just in the idea of
maintaining as quick as we
possibly can.
IVAN POSVA: Yeah,
so basically, it
sounds like the embedding
of a shared library
is more the kind of stuff
that you would need, right?
And you can import,
basically, these libraries
with a special prefix
and the VM figures out
that, oh, I need not just
to load the Dart code.
I also need to bind
this shared library.
And then, you have
similar to a JNI API.
But we try to make it a
lot simpler than using JNI.
AUDIENCE: I'll ask
you more after.
Thank you.
SETH LADD: Thank you.
Question?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Have you considered adding
support for algebraic data
types or pattern marching
into the language at all?
LARS BAK: I can take a
short stab at that one.
We have considered
a lot of stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
There's been a lot
of requests for many
of these advanced features.
However, whenever we
add an advanced feature,
it gets harder to use
the basic language.
We designed Dart so it's
easier to understand what's
going on when you execute it.
So when you're
sitting inside a debug
or you take a single step, you
know exactly what's going on.
When you add these advanced
features like pattern matching,
it gets a little bit more
complicated to figure out
what's going on at one time.
Of course, if there's not
enough requests for it,
we will certainly
look at and put it in.
We have a process called the
dev process, where everybody
can add a proposal and send it
into us and we will look at it
and put it in if it's
good for the language.
However, whenever
you add something
to a programming language,
it gets more complicated.
And I really believe that if
you have a simple execution
in your programming
language, then people
will understand what's going on
and they'll be more productive.
So that's the balance
we have to consider.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
Good way to end it.
And with that,
we're out of time.
So thank you for everyone who
voted and asked questions.
Let's thank our panelists.
[APPLAUSE]
We'll see you after the break.